قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان نجاح روسيا
في اوكرانيا قد يشجع الصين على غزو تايوان
وفي معرض رده على سؤال للسنه الجمهوريه
الانستجرام خلال جلسه استماع عقدتها لجنه
الاعتمادات في مجلس الشيوخ اضاف استون ان
نجاح روسيا في اوكرانيا لن يشجع الصين فقط
بل جهات فاعله سيئه اخرى حول العالم على
حد وصفه
اذا تراجعنا وتركنا بوتين ينجح في
اوكرانيا فمن المرجح ان تغزو الصين تايوان
هل تتفق مع هذا الطرح
اتفق معك ليست الصين فقط بل سنرى ايضا
جهات فاعله سيئه اخرى حول العالم تفعل
الشيء نفسه
وتحديدا ما قاله وزير الدفاع الامريكي
عبد القادر هذه الجلسه كانت في لجنه
الاعتمادات شهد فيها كل من وزير الدفاع
لويد اوستن وزير الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن
ووزيره التجاره
جورجينا في هذه الجلسه هؤلاء المسؤولين
الثلاثه عنوانها كان التنافس مع الصين في
اطار النقاشات الدائره حول
الموازنه الموازنه المقبله
لوزاره الخارجيه والدفاع والحكومه
الامريكيه بشكل عام وهنا قلق المشارعين
الامريكيين ازاء هذا التحدي الذي تمثله
الصين وهذا ما سمعناه على لسان المسؤولين
الثلاثه بان الصين تمثل التحدي الجيوسياسي
الذي سيكون له التبعات والعواقب الاكثر
على الولايات المتحده التحدي الذي وهي
منافس للولايات المتحده تريد من تغيير
الواقع حول العالم المسؤولون الثلاثه
اشاروا الى انه
المتحده لا تسعى الى احتواء الصين لا يمكن
ان تفرض على الصين ان تغير من مسارها ولكن
بامكانها ان تضع نفسها في موقع يمكن
الولايات المتحده من ان تتفوق على الصين
من حيث المنافسه الامنيه والعسكريه
والاقتصاديه والتكنولوجيا وما الى ذلك
فيما يتعلق بتايوان تحديدا وهذا هو القلق
الاكبر سمعنا من وزير الدفاع يقول ان
الولايات المتحده على وشك ان تمنح تايوان
مساعدات امنيه اضافيه وفق ما كان قد فوضه
ووافق عليه الكونجرس العام الماضي وانه في
رد على سؤال ان كان
التخلف او تخلف الولايات المتحده عن تقديم
الدعم لاوكرانيا وفتح المجال امام روسيا
كي تنجح في حربها في اوكرانيا فهل كان ذلك
او هل سيساهم ذلك في ان يشجع الصين على
غزوه تايوان سمعنا من وزير الدفاعي يوافق
على هذه او هذا السؤال او هذا الطرح القول
انه ايضا سيشجع دولا اخرى او عناصر اخرى
حول العالم من ان تقدم على اعمال مماثله
بالنسبه لوزير الخارجيه ايضا اشار الى انه
عبر ادارات متلاحقه كان هناك التزام من
قبل الادارات الامريكيه من جمهوريه
وديمقراطيه في سياسه الصين الواحده
والقانون العلاقات مع تايوان وجلب ذلك
نفعا وفائده على تايوان على الولايات
المتحده وعلى الصين ايضا
وساهم في وضع فهم عام بانه لا يمكن لبلد
من ان يغير الوضع القائم ويهدد الامن
والاستقرار ولكن وفق ما يرصده او ترصده
الادارات الامريكيه مؤخرا وهذا ما قاله
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتمي بلينكن فان
الصين يبدو انها تريد ان تغير من الوضع
القائم وتزيد من ضغوطها على تايوان وهذا
ما يقلق الاداره الام ريكيه والمشرعين هنا
في الكونغرس عبد القادر
شكرا جزيلا لك